introduce our first speaker, Gang Wang,
which will be sharing about the directed evolution
in non-human primates, which identifies the AAV capsits
with the novel motive enabling efficient muscle
targeting and reduced liver tropism.
Sorry about that.
Just before Gang starts,
I just a reminder that no flash photography
is allowed.
And if you haven't connected to the west in this wall room,
the password is ASGCT 2026.
And without any further ado, welcome, Gang.
Thank you.
Thank you for the introduction.
Good morning, everyone.
I'm Gang Wang from Beyond Genes Therapeutics.
It's my honor to be here today.
I will introduce our capsaid engineering platform
and we identified muscle targeting motive
by this platform.
And this motive can be effectively tuned
for optimal liberty targeting.
All these findings come from
our platform, Dynamo-Lib.
We have a capsaid libraries.
We have a calibrator,
the calibrated barcoded libraries,
and in vivo validation system
combined with the capture, the signal recovery system.
This pipeline allows us to find the clinical lead.
Parasite is our capsaid library.
We have two distinct kind of library.
One is a random peptide insertion.
We are eight of AV9 capsaid.
Another one is a rationally designed peptide
derived from a cell surface binding protein.
And we use a dual DNA packaging system.
This system yield a very high viral titer of library
and this also achieves very good high-fusility packaging
with very low backbone contamination
and excellent consistency of phenotype and genotype.
A calibrator is our calibrated barcoded library.
We use AV9 as internal standards
with different doses.
And then we create central curve
based on the dosage of AV9
and the in vivo t-show expression.
And then all variants are mapped to this curve
to calculate normalized for the change against AV9.
In chemo, we label the different variants
with distinct epitope tags
for multi-level capsaid benchmarking in a single animal.
This is our signal recovery platform.
We named the capture with magnetic bits
contracted with a virus-specific probe
to recover the viral MRI.
And this method facilitated the RT preparation
from a large amount of NHP tissues.
This is our integrated dynamo-lib.
We integrated multi-librates, multi-root,
and multi-tissue screening,
all in a single NHP model.
The aim is to maximize the data output per NHP.
This strategy is very productive.
From intravenous delivery,
we identified mild-cap series targeting to muscle
and the lead candidate targeting to deep brain.
From intracecho delivery,
we identified syn-cap series
which can transduce almost all NHP
looking at cells.
Now we move to our discovery
of muscle targeting motif.
And this is the first round in vivo screening.
At this early stage,
we didn't find a reliable linear motif,
but we found a very strong argument
about the arginine accumulation across all clusters.
In the second round screening,
we eyes the selection pressure increase,
R6, the arginine at the sixth position accumulated dramatically.
And we then analyzed the round of the R6 anchor
revealed that dominant PRT motif
across all the muscles and the heart.
And then we recasturing fixed R energy
and we confirmed that it's the first round
R energy and we confirmed that it's the PRG motif.
And then we verified this motif in different species
and we select four PRG variants
and package them individually,
label them with different IPP attacks
and mix them together and then
admit to animal by intravenous injection.
And we tested them in Rhesus macaque
SDRS and two species of mice.
And all the PRT variants show a higher muscle expression
than AB9 and the best one is BY087.
And then we further validated BY087 in Rhesus macaque
and at the dose of five times the power of 12,
VG protege, BY087 outperforms every now across
DNA, MRI and protein levels in all tested muscles.
And since we have already verified the PRG motif,
then we did the optimization of this PRG motif
and the structure modeling by alpha fold
reveals that there is a distinct protrusion
introduced by SALTPRG insertion of BY087.
We hypothesized, optimized the
and terminal of the PRG motif could be
maximized the muscle potency of the PRG.
So we established the next round of HP screening
by NNK saturation library.
And the correlation analysis of the NNK library screening
revealed that there is a very strong positive correlation
between muscle expression and the liver expression.
First, we identified the consensus sequence
for muscle tropism, it is SAXY PRG.
And then we focus on the afterlife population
as shown in the right color with high muscle expression
and low liver expression compared to the background.
We found a distinct Hesidian accumulation
in the second position and the fourth position.
We named it the H switch.
And then we developed our next generation
male cap from white lab direct evolution
and the structure informed design using H switch.
And also the AI guide discovery
to expand our candidate.
Finally, we got 32 unique next generation variants
and we tested them using our calibrator platform.
The result shows most of the next generation variants
show a higher muscle expression than BY 087.
And the H switch works in the same way
very well in these variants.
When the double H incorporation
achieves very high muscle liver ratio
around 32 times and 23 times,
it's much higher than the BY 087.
It is only 3.8 fold.
And the single H incorporation is also very effective.
It reached the ratio of 17 fold.
And then we selected the two kind of variants.
The blue one is the muscle potency
and the right one is the liberally targeting group.
And for the right group,
it's much published mile away.
And this is the BY 438 result in calibrator.
And the linear, we can see the linear regression of AV9.
And also we can see the muscle expression here
for the BY 488, much higher than AV9.
And with liver, less expressed in the liver.
And then we make higher to higher comparison
between BY 438 and AV9.
And we can see the BY 483 expressed much higher MRI
in muscles than liver.
And only 40% MRI expression in liver compared to AV9.
The protein, the IF 10 confirmed protein expression
consistent with MRI expression.
This is the last presentation slide.
We did cross species validation in Santa Mogas
for myocardium variants.
And the H switch works very well in Santa Mogas.
It's actually for the double H incorporation.
As shown in red color,
the auto-perform the published control myocardium and VG7.
For conclusion, Danily is end-to-end pipeline
for calibrator discovery.
And the PRD motif, so as a strong muscle targeting motif
while flanking H residue,
acts as a precise switch to abolish the level of targeting.
The myocype series, like BY 438,
demonstrate a special muscle transduction
and hepatic escape in other HP,
serving as ideal vector for muscle-related gene therapy.
Thank you.
Thank you, Gang.
Do we have any questions for Gang?
We have one minute.
I'm sorry, I may have missed it.
Did you mention the receptor that you believe
this is binding to?
No, we are trying to find the receptor.
Unfortunately, until now, we didn't find it.
Hi, I'm nice to talk.
You mentioned that you use dose calibration curve
in your libraries.
I'm curious how you use that data on the other end
and what you've learned about dose response
of various AV variants.
You mean the mechanism of our calibrator?
Yeah, like how you use the calibrator data?
Yeah, we have our algorithm, calibrated algorithm,
and we use the change fold,
change fold to represent the potency of each variant.
We get the T2 expression data,
put them, might put them into the standard curve
and then we will calculate the fold change
compared to the standard curve.
That means the increase fold against the AV9.
Okay, thank you.
Thank you, Gang.
With that, I would like to invite our next speaker,
Benjamin, and he is my joint collaboration
of the Tevira Therapeutics
and the Department of Cellular and Molecular Medicine
in Belgium, so welcome, Benjamin.
Thank you, it's nice being here.
So today I wanted to tell you a little bit
about what we have been doing with Tevira
over the last year and we've been working
on a novel capsa platform,
which we call the DEV platform, some of my disclosures.
So I think I'm preaching to the choir here
when I say that AV development is kind of hindered
by the specificity and the potency of AV vectors
and also the manufacturing can be sometimes
always quite complex.
So at Tevira, we wondered, okay,
can we make this more streamlined and more directed
by zip coding AVs to send them directly
to specific tissues in a rational way?
And the way we did that is through
what we call our DEV platform,
stands for Decorated AVs.
What we basically did is we started
with a parental AV serotype and in our case,
we checked the AV2 and AV9, but we went ahead with AV9
and we did some minimal vector engineering.
What we did was we added in the surfaces post loops,
we added a recognition tag for an enzyme called sortase A.
And what happens is this sortase can recognize this tag
and then when it does so it can attach targeting groups
to the capsits and these targeting groups
then afford specificity and potency of the vector.
So as you see here, this tag is in all the viral proteins
of the capsits.
So here a little animation, how it works.
You see the tag is in the pink loops.
The sortase recognizes it and a targeting group.
In this case, I'm just showing a VHH domain
but can be anything, comes in, recognizes it
and is covalently attached to the capsits.
So how do we make it?
So basically just make the AV first
and we go to our up and downstream manufacturing.
Then we do the conjugation in what we sometimes refer
to as a shake and bake reaction.
You just incubate it for a given amount of time
at room temperature after which you purify out
the enzyme in the non-reactive targeting groups.
And that affords a very strong platform modularity.
As I said, we can do with AV2, with AV9,
we can target several surface exposed loops.
Some of them work better than the other
and we can target anything from small molecules
to VHH domains on those capsits.
And that makes that we have a predictable
and reproducible product.
So we have confirmed the structure
of these conjugated molecules using mass spec.
We can quantify them using Westerblot and Eliza assays.
And when we do transduction assays,
we see in vitro that it is nice and reproducible.
So the first thing we did for just for the heck of it,
I guess, was conjugating biotin to it.
And what you can see here on the left-hand side,
that is a non-conjugated AV vector.
You see the VP123 bands.
And then when we do the conjugation with biotin,
if we just stain for the viral protein,
we have basically the C terminal fragment.
So that is downstream of the recognition side
that you see here at the bottom.
And that's the sort of cleft fragment.
So that confirms the conjugation.
But then when we also look at the biotin staining,
that is attached to the N terminal fragment
of the viral protein,
you see that we conjugate both VP1, VP2N, VP3 of the capsits.
So that's all really good,
but we don't care too much about biotin.
So we want to do cell targeting.
And again, in the early days of this platform,
when we just wanted to validate this,
we used the HER2 binding VHH.
And what you can see is in HER2 negative cells,
we barely have any transduction.
That's because we do the specific engineering
that makes the capsit, basically,
not transduced so well in any cell type.
But then when we conjugate the HER2 VHH,
we have specific targeting.
Again, HER2, not super interesting for us.
What we wanted to do is we wanted to reach the CNS.
And we did that with, obviously, the transfer receptor,
what so many others are doing as well,
trying to piggyback on that receptor,
shuttling across the anothelial cells
to get into the brain prankima.
And that's what you can see here.
We started off with a mouse transfer receptor
in mouse transfer receptor overexpressing cells.
But crucially, we also went into human transfer
receptor positive cells.
And you can see that compared to NAV9,
our constructs have, at least in vitro,
an 18-fold improved transduction efficiency.
Of course, again, we don't want to transduce
HDFR positive cells.
We want to cross the BBB.
And so we did an in vivo bi-distribution study.
So what we did is just with a GFP reporter gene
and human transfer receptor knock in mice
at those of 5V, 11VG per mouse.
We injected this IV and we looked at the bi-distribution.
So on the left here, you see AV9.
That's kind of typical of what we would see at this dose.
But then when we took our lead CNS, Dave Kapsit,
you see that we have nice and widespread
brain distribution, including the deeper brain areas.
And if we zoom in a little bit here in the top row,
you can see AV9 with a new end counterstain for neurons.
And in the bottom row, you can see our Dave Kapsit.
And again, you see that almost all brain regions
are efficiently transduced.
Of course, we want to quantify this.
So here on the left-hand side,
you see the VG copies in the brain.
And you see that we have two logs
improvement in brain targeting.
And then when we look at the neuronal transduction,
you see that we have anywhere depending on the brain region
between 20% and 80% of the neurons transduced,
which I think is quite important
and strongly improved relative to, for instance, AV9.
Very importantly, the liver, of course,
if we go systemic with many Kapsits out there,
you see they end up in the liver
associated with liver tox.
Our Dave Kapsits are, again, two log
de-targeted from the liver on the VG level.
And that's something that is inherent to our platform.
So we see the same effect if we don't conjugate.
So this is really due to how we do the engineering
in the Kapsits.
And basically these 100-fold improvement in brain targeting
and 100-fold reduction in liver targeting
opens up that therapeutic window with four logs.
So that's on CNS.
But of course, this is platform technology.
We don't only want to target CNS.
We want to go more broadly as well.
There's a large need for Kapsits that target kidney.
There's a large number of genetic kidney diseases
with devastating outcomes and very limited treatment options.
So we said, okay, can we make vectors, AV vectors,
that more strongly target cell types in the kidney?
And we focused on a little bit of polycytes.
I'm not showing you that work today,
but also we focus on tubular epithelial cells
with a vision of treating tuberopathies down the line.
And what you can see here, this is just in vitro data.
We're still working on the in vivo work,
but you see that again here compared to an AV9
in cell culture, we have that 20-fold improvement
in cell targeting with our ligand tree here.
So we're still improving on that.
We think that we haven't reached the ceiling.
We can do some engineering there on both the Kapsits
and the ligand level to improve that.
And at the same time, Tevira is planning to put this
in an in vivo study.
So to summarize, the Dave platform that we have developed
gives a modular design for designing potents,
but also very specific AV Kapsits.
It's something, these post-manufactured conjugation
technologies, and I think we will hear some more about it
in this session, that has a strong potential
to rationally engineer AV Kapsits
also in a human targeted context.
Our platform can do that by enzymatic conjugation
with an inherent liberty targeting.
We have strong proof of concept for CNS targeting
and then in vitro proof of concept in kidney targeting,
which we will further work on.
Of course, this is work that we haven't done alone.
We developed the Dave platform was initially developed
at the University of Leuven,
which we whom we have a collaboration.
And with that, I would like to thank you for your attention
and take any question you have.
Thank you Benjamin.
And so floor is open for questions.
Great talk, real simple system.
Are you disclosing just how many of the subunits
are either contain your targeting loop
and then after conjugation contain
an actual conjugation event?
We're not disclosing it, but I don't want to disappoint you.
So I'll say it's not 60 and it's not zero.
So we know that, the reason is if we go too high
and that's what others have seen as well,
then you end up with a particle that's not really an AV.
It's an AV covered in a number of molecules
and probably it doesn't traffic as well in the cell.
So we see that we can go quite low.
And it depends a bit on the system
and on the ligand that you attach and so on and so forth.
But the exact number is currently not disclosed.
Okay, thank you.
Hi.
Hi, my name is Lou Johnson from Ohio.
Sorry.
Oh, sorry.
Yeah.
Okay, the retina is part of the CNS.
Did you look and see if you get any targeting in the retina?
Sorry, come again?
The retina is part of the central nervous system.
We did not look at the retina though.
Maybe we can go further.
Okay.
Thank you.
Really wonderful talk.
Very impressive data.
So I'm just curious.
You mentioned that the conjugation was specific
to the real one, real four and the H.
I'm just curious.
Is the conjugation, how can you like specifically
conjugate to a specific loop
or it is actually not specific?
So we do the, we add the tag by which,
so the sort is recognized a tag, it's five amino acids
and we add that either to loop four or to loop eight.
Okay, so the tag is in the genome, AV genome.
Packaging.
Yes, the tag is in the genetic sequence of the capsic.
Thank you very much.
Capsic, yes.
Hi, great talk.
So I have a quick question about how your retargeting impacts
the secondary interaction with AVR.
Have you looked at that and do you know if you're forcing
AV through different like uptake pathways
once you've initially bound through
transparent receptor or whatever?
We have not looked at that.
No, it's something that has come up in the past.
In one of the earlier versions of the capsid that we had,
we saw very funky results.
And then we were thinking somewhat the interaction
with AVR or all the receptors in mind,
and especially the trafficking as a whole
might be impacted.
And then we did some re-engineering,
solved the problem and didn't look back.
We haven't looked at it with this specific version
of the capsid.
Thank you very much.
Does your HFTR TFR targeted capsid also recognize
the Sino receptor?
Yes, although, and that's the case with any capsid,
we know that there's a gap between the affinity,
for instance, for Sino and human.
So it does recognize, so we are pretty comfortable
going into an HP studies with the caveat
that of course it's a different system.
So, but it does recognize, yes, thanks.
Thank you, great talk, just a quick question.
Why do you think the NCNS like deep brain structures
such as telomeres being targeted by the conjugated?
It's highly vascularized.
Oh, okay.
Since we have a little bit of time,
I have my own questions.
So, how do you remove the unbound or the,
if there is something in there in the system, not the...
Yeah, so after the conjugation...
The purification process?
Yes, so after the conjugation,
which is just an incubation,
we do a purification system currently.
We were using small scales,
so we're using something like a dialysis
or a size exclusion, but of course at larger scales,
we intend to do it with a TFF process, for instance,
or an extra affinity capture step.
Okay, thank you, Andrew.
Great talk.
Follow-up question on the synomologous macaques.
Do you have data?
No, not yet.
That's in the making.
So, we have data on binding,
how the ligand itself binds to the sinus receptor,
but no indevo data on that yet.
We can take questions from the...
Oh, sorry.
Yeah.
So, I have two questions.
First one about the stability of the capsid
after these conjugations.
Do you have any idea about that?
And also, the surface modifications could introduce
like new immunogenic epitopes.
So, are you planning to do like any immunogenic studies?
Yeah, so the first one was the stability.
So, what we have seen is sometimes inserting these loops
destabilizes the capsid prior to conjugation,
so those are variants that we discarded.
Gaging the thermal stability of the capsid
after conjugation is not super straightforward
because you have multiple variants there.
What we see is that we have pretty good transduction.
So, we assume that the quaternary structure still holds
also because we don't fully conjugate the whole particle.
So, there's only a number of sites that are conjugated.
But we haven't measured it directly.
The second thing is the epitopes.
Immunogenic epitopes.
So, basically what we add is just these five amino acids
which is LPETG.
We don't assume, we assume they're not immunogenic
and they haven't been shown in other systems
to be immunogenic.
And then we just have the nanobody, for instance,
or the targeting group that is there.
So, the sortase is fully out.
It's not attached to the capsid anymore.
But we will measure that in our NHP studies for sure.
Okay, one last question.
You showed a series of different AV conjugates.
Are they different nanobodies
or just different formulations, same nanobody?
They are different ligands.
And you're referring to the...
I can give you an example for the neural lines.
For instance, here, ligand one, two, and three,
they are different ligands.
Oh, okay, okay.
With that, thank you, Benjamin.
Thank you.
Moving on to our third speaker.
We welcome Luizha Zhang.
She will be talking about the uncoupling capsid structure,
functional performance,
and clinical translation of AAV virons.
Well, thank you.
And as always, I want to thank the organizers
for the opportunity to present our work.
My name is Luizhan Song.
I've been presenting on behalf of the team.
So I'll be talking about uncoupling capsid structure,
functional performance,
and the clinical translation of AAV virons,
very non-title.
So here are my disclosures.
So to engineer capsids,
we have so many different strategies
that could be used, right?
So we could do site-direct mutagenesis.
We could do shuffling.
We could do a lot of things,
aeroprom, PCR, AI, machine learning,
directory evolution.
But one of the strategies we are using,
usually we show a common goal.
It's very similar that we want our capsid to be
detected from the lever,
and we want the capsid to cross a certain
biologic barrier better,
or we want the capsid to target,
to transduce our target cells or tissues better
at higher efficiency.
This is the common goal,
but today I don't want to share
another exciting capsid engineering success story.
Instead, I wanted to share some of our observations
on a few candidates that are in our capsid engineering
process, and hopefully that could provide you
a little bit additional perspective or considerations
when we think about capsid engineering
and the clinical translation.
So, I'd like to hear this slide.
How do I go back?
Yeah, okay, yes.
Oh, this is the one.
Yeah, so here this slide introduce you,
introduce all the capsid that I'll be discussing
throughout this presentation.
So, firstly, AV-9 will obviously
is our parent capsid,
and this is our benchmark control,
and AV-902, O3, O4, and these are
the in-house engineered capsid variants.
So, these variants were engineered
either including some mutations on the VR1 region,
or it has the peptide insertion at the VRH region,
or a combination of both,
and all these peptide candidates are identified
in our previous NHP Direct Evolution libraries.
So, our structure specialist
analyzed the structure as everyone do.
So, as you can see, the VP3 unit structure
is usually highly conserved,
and the VRH structure actually is very flexible
where you insert the peptide.
So, the structure is a little bit difficult
to predict accurately.
So, our structure specialist also
analyzed the surface potential charges, those charges.
So, if we, basically the red
stands for the positive charge
and the blue stands for the negative charge,
and the white or gray, it stands for the neutral charge.
So, if we subtract the AV-9 from the variants,
you can see there are some differences
become more obvious that the variants
introduced on the surface of the capsid.
And if we take a closer look,
you can see at the tri-fold, at the three-fold axis,
there will be show some different pattern
across different candidates.
And one of the things interesting
on the bottom right middle panel for the AV-03,
you can see there is a strong positive patch
at the three-fold.
So, when we work on the capsid,
it's very natural to speculate or imagine,
maybe this could do something.
So, maybe this kind of feature could affect their AV life cycle
or some type of trope or something.
Now I will show you how does each of these capsid
perform in the animal models.
So, just for your information that we actually
have another talk, we are happy right after this session
where Dr. Jules Muske will present our recent
clinical data if you are interested in.
So, here I'm just showing the animal data.
So, firstly, AV-901, this is a very busy slide,
but I want to draw your attention to this bar graph.
And you can see, hopefully, the second bar
represents the liver, so at the DNA level,
you can see that this capsid appears
to be a liver-detocated capsid.
And you can see all the bars which represent
for the brain, different part of the brain
and the spinal cord.
Then you can tell they are actually having more copies
compared to AV-9, which indicating that this capsid
is crossing BBB better.
And we also, of course, examined the RNA protein
and it appears that we have a liver-detocated capsid
and it crossed the BBB better.
And it has a very kind of good transduction profile
for the motor neurons.
So, the next one I'm showing you here is the AV-902,
which you can see is also liver-detocated
and it transduces the spinal cord of the brain well,
but it doesn't really cross the BBB significantly better
than the AV-9 and even a little bit worse or similar.
So, we think this capsid is liver-detocated,
but it doesn't cross BBB more efficiently,
but it does transduce the serum at similar
or comparable level compared to AV-9.
So, the very last two AV-903,
now four AV-904 works very quickly.
From the DNA level, you can tell it is not liver-detocated
capsid at all, but it does cross the BBB better,
more efficiently.
So,
so just to summarize what I just showed you
in the animal are animals.
So, it appears that for this four AV-9 variants,
we have AV-1901 and 02 appear to be liver-detocated
and we have all these capsid except the AV-902
appear to not better than AV-9 in crossing the BBB,
but all others across the BBB better.
And they all transduce the urine pretty well,
but the next major question is how would this translate
to therapeutic effect when we put it on the animal models?
So, here I'm going to show you the performance
in the disease model.
Here we are using the very famous Delta-7SMA mouse model,
which is originally established by Dr. Burgess
at the Ohio State University.
And this is the mouse model, the key mouse model
that successfully supports the DSMA development,
the eventual approver.
So, this actually is kind of rapidly then a model
that could kind of predict the translatability
for the capsids for the CNS disease implications.
So, we packed all these AV-9 variants
into a CCE AV format,
and then we packed the same human SMM1 gene,
a stethogensma.
So, then we put these vectors into the animal model.
And here I'm going to show you just one dataset,
which is the survival data.
Of course, we test all the other stuff,
like the body weight, the motor functions, everything,
but here just the survival data.
And here you can see the dotted line
represent the non-trading mouse,
and the black line represent the AV-9,
which is similar to Zogesma.
And then here is the AV-901,
which actually from the biodestribution expression data,
we know that this is a liver-detocated capsid,
and it crossed the BBB efficiently,
much more efficiently compared to AV-9,
and actually it transduces our target cell,
which is the modern neuron cell pretty well,
but it didn't rescue the phenotypes in the SMM1 model
compared to AV-9, it doesn't rescue better than AV-9.
And the AV-902, which is also a liver-detocated capsid,
but it didn't cross the BBB more efficiently
compared to AV-9, it actually works very well
on the SMM1 model.
The third and the fourth capsid,
if you still remember the big table,
the three and the four, they are very similar to each other
in terms of the biodestribution or expression profile,
but eventually there are a therapeutic effect
on this model, it's totally different.
The AV-903 is similar or actually worse compared to AV-9,
but the AV-904, that just works perfectly,
even at lower dose, I forgot the exact dose,
but it could be up to a lower dose compared to AV-9,
can still rescue the phenotypes.
So this is very interesting because these two peptides,
as I said, they are all NHP,
they are library directory evolution,
they are top candidates for targeting the CNS,
they are supposed to cross the BBB better,
and they are very similar profiling
all what our preclinic evaluation,
but eventually they are performed totally differently
in the SMM1 models.
And the one more interesting thing is actually three and four,
they contain the same mutations as AV-902,
which in AV-902, these mutations in the VA1
actually resulted in liver detoxing,
but when we combine the top candidates,
the peptide candidates together with this,
we are one mutations, they are not liver detoxing anymore.
So they are talking to each other,
even one is at a VR8, one is at a VR1.
So here is the data and the summary,
it ends up that we have expected or unexpected,
we have two capsules that works better than AV-9,
and two capsules is actually work worse than AV-9.
So I think it is obvious that there are some
like biology behind this phenomena
that we may need to pay a little more attention
or considerations when we talk about capsules engineering.
And I would say our observation may demonstrate
that the importance of the deriving translation capsules
versus the best transducing capsules,
we should always consider everything together,
the structure, the performance,
and we should choose the appropriate animal disease model
to evaluate the real potential for the clinical translation.
So with that, I'd like to conclude the talk
by thanking all my team members
for their tremendous support and all their contributions.
Specifically, I want to thank Sophia,
she carried out all the structure analysis for the team,
and Zhongliang basically led all the UVA experiments,
the main takes care of all the production aspect.
And I thank Dr. Jules Muski
for letting me to lead the project,
and I thank everyone, thank you for your attention.
And I'm happy to take any questions.
Thank you.
Any questions for Liu?
Come on, give me some questions, please.
Not so many.
Thank you very much.
It was an interesting talk.
My name is Adrian from Geneton.
Nice to meet you.
So when you look at your capsid bio-distribution
and the actual effect it had in the disease models,
what cells do you think actually need to be targeted
for curative effect?
For SMA, we majorly want the motor urine
to be transduced in the spinal cord.
And also because based on the SMA1 protein atlas in humans,
it's not just the motor urine has the SMA1 expression.
So we think other cells or organs
may need certain levels of transduction.
But majorly, we want the motor urine to be transduced.
And do you think the motor urine transduction
can happen outside of the CNS?
So if they're peripherally transduced, it's enough.
Since you had non-BBB crossing variants,
that still had a curative effect.
I'm sorry, I may miss your question.
What's the question?
Do you think the motor neurons need to be transduced
in the CNS or can they be transduced peripherally?
And then the AV retrograde the transports to the nucleus?
I still don't think I get the question 100%.
But I think the motor urine in the spinal cord,
yeah, we do wanna target one high transduction.
But for the peripheral tissues, we wanna,
so no capsules that's really targeting the CNS,
like absolutely, like 100%, right?
You always have a disfunction in the peripheral tissues.
I'm asking for the peripheral neurons.
Because the motor neurons obviously starts in the CNS.
That's something we haven't checked yet.
We don't know, we don't have data.
We'll do the next question.
Gadex coffin gene therapeutics optimized.
I'm curious, I may have missed it,
but do you have any data in human cells yet
or any tropism?
We are building on AV agilis in humans, yes.
We are going to publish very soon.
For certain capsules, not all capsules, obviously.
Can you share whether these ones were found in that atlas?
This one is still ongoing.
We haven't connected any data yet.
Yeah, on human, not yet.
Thank you.
Interesting talk.
I'm Travis from Genentech.
You know, BBV transcytosis and liver transduction
can both be affected by AVR binding.
I was curious if you looked at AVR binding with your capsules.
We did a structure analysis,
but just to be honest,
we didn't do the structure cryoEM.
No, we didn't.
And we didn't do the affinity test, no.
But we do what everyone do is do the structure prediction,
the binding assay by the computer.
It is consistent, inconsistent in a way.
We don't find any of variants of the indirect
with AVR PKD1 domain,
but for the PKD2 domain,
for the AV901, it actually shows stronger binding
compared to AV9, but it is liver detected,
so which is a little bit contradictory
to what everyone, including myself,
thought it would happen.
And for the AV902, it is consistent
with what we currently thought it would be.
So it has less binding affinity.
And AV903 and AV04, I'm a little bit forgetting,
but it seems to be stronger,
which consistent because 903 is not liver detected,
and it has stronger binding.
But again, AV901 is higher binding,
but liver detected, so it's hard to explain.
Thank you.
That would thank Luis.
So for that, I would invite our next speaker
from Sanofi Saurav Chaudhry,
and he will be talking about the metagenomics
AAV caches with deep petascale mining.
Welcome, Saurav.
Well, thank you, Smriti.
And I'd like to start by thanking the organizers
for this opportunity to talk about our work.
Here's my disclosure slide, and my title slide.
About 50% of the human population
is ineligible for a gene therapy trial.
And that is largely because of neutralizing antibodies
that humans have.
Actually, can we switch to the non-presenter mode?
Just the slides, full screen, please.
Thank you.
Now, the reason human populations
have neutralizing antibodies is largely
because we have exposure to natural AV capsids
throughout life, but also because humans
have co-evolved with capsids of primate origin.
And as you guys know, every single capsid
we have in a clinical trial is either of primate origin
or has been engineered from primate origin.
So it's a massive problem.
We hypothesized that if we could find capsids
from a non-primate origin,
we'd be able to get around this problem.
Now, we're not the first ones to do it.
There are landmark papers that have done it before.
But one of the things that we thought
was relatively unexplored is the heterogenomic space
or the extra genomic space.
So to aid discovery from that,
we build this custom-built capsid discovery pipeline
called MATCAP.
I know you've up to your neck in acronyms, this is ours.
The challenge with finding or mining metagenomes,
capsids from metagenomes is just the scale
at which you have to find.
It's literally a proverbial needle in a haystack.
We have about four, if you just go to NCBI,
you have about 4.2 million SRAs or Sequence Read Archives
that you have to search through,
and that represents petabytes of data.
So we built this three-layer screen
where we first did a more crude screen
to just identify SRAs that had power viral reads.
So out of these 4.2 million, we landed about 12,000 of them.
And then we essentially assembled these contexts de novo
by overlapping these reads through Synoteca II,
and then these contexts were annotated,
and we identified novel AAV capsids
from that batch of things.
Using this method, we found capsids throughout the globe.
We found a lot of capsids from the US,
which is not surprising because there is a lot of studies
in metagenomic studies in wastewater from the US,
but we also found a lot of capsids in Southeast Asia.
We found capsids in a variety of architectures.
We found linear capsids.
We found in complete genomes,
with just the capsidum and no rep.
We found capsids that looked like they could be circular
in their genomes, not entirely clear why.
But as a summation, we found about 139 novel capsids.
So just to set the scale,
this about doubles the universe of known AAV capsidum.
So that's what we found in this class of variants.
What is particularly interesting in this cladogram
that you see is the divergent madcap sequence.
So divergent madcap sequence is a sequence
that we actually could not find a close natural relative to.
There wasn't really a base capsid or a parental capsid
that we could see that it had evolved away from.
And that's what we're gonna talk about throughout this talk,
and focus on, given the context of what we were searching for.
In this data set, we are looking at percentage neutralization.
And I like to point you out sort of the two big buckets
of capsids that we were able to find.
There's this blue bucket, right?
Which is mildly neutralizable.
They get neutralized, especially as you keep increasing
the concentration of human IVIG,
which contains preexisting neutralizing antibodies
throughout the globe.
They are much better compared to the black lines there,
which are the natural isolates like AV1, AV2, and AV9.
And then you have what we think is the most promising one,
which are the pink squiggly lines, the pink capsids here,
which are these non-neutralizing capsids
that do not seem to hit 50% neutralization
at any concentration of IVIG that we dose.
There's literally no nab response
that we could record for these, which is very surprising.
We have not seen that previously.
This is just the same data graphed out differently
to show you the gulf between the natural isolates,
the neutralizable mat caps,
and the completely non-neutralizable mat caps.
We decided to focus on two of these pink capsids,
two of the non-neutralizable mat caps, MC46 and MC55.
Again, more acronyms.
I'll talk to you about in a second
of why we decided to focus on it,
but the first thing to show is that
because these are caps as we haven't seen before,
we confirm that these are able to package,
these are able to make what we consider classic virions.
But very interestingly, when we dose them
into a non-human primate, these stood out significantly
compared to AV9.
You can see AV9 on the bottom right of the curve,
high neutralization, but low brain penetrance,
and you can see MC55, and especially MC46,
on the left of that curve.
If you look at where they are on the cladogram
in relation to other capsids,
what you're seeing here in the purple Manhattan skyscrapers
is the extent to which they can be neutralized.
And you can clearly point out with those two boxes
that MC45, MC46 is completely non-neutralizable,
whereas MC55 has a degree of neutralization,
but is much less compared to its neighbors
and natural isolates.
Here is a representative brain map
showing the brain penetrance of MC46 and MC55
compared to AV9.
What you're seeing on the left is DNA fitness,
or DNA recounts.
What you're seeing on the right of this brain heat map
is the RNA, and you can see that we think that MC46
and MC55 show widespread transduction
of the non-human primate brain after intravenous delivery.
We wanted to next confirm how good,
or how good at avoiding nab neutralization are these capsids.
So we basically compared them
to their closest natural isolate.
I'm just showing you this MSA just to show you
that when we say closest is not very close,
it's actually quite far,
but their closest natural isolates,
and we benchmarked it to AV1 and AV9.
And what you're seeing here is basically
person neutralization in about 15
individual human donors that we sourced.
And what you can see here, the more yellier you get,
the more seropositive these donors are
for a specific capsid.
And what you can see is that your natural AV capsids,
a majority of donors are seropositive for them.
As you go to MC55, which is the last but one column,
you can see that few donors are seropositive.
And as you get to MC46,
we did not see a single donor out of the 15
that was seropositive.
We've actually done this exact study
with about 100 non-human primates right now,
and we found two that maybe could be seropositive.
We also confirmed that if you take serum from these donors,
you are still able to get full transduction
with MC46 and MC55.
Now the next question is, if that is true,
is this a paradigm for re-dosing?
What we confirmed is that MC46 transduction
is unaffected by prior AV dosing.
So on the left, we are showing you
this passive transfer model,
where rodents are pre-dosed with human IVIG,
and then they are challenged with AV.
And what you can see is that as expected,
AV9 completely loses all transduction
if in a passive transfer mouse model,
which is rescued by IDES, as expected.
On the other hand, MC46 loses none of its transduction.
And a pretty similar assay on the right,
where we are showing that in rodents
that are dosed with AV1, or AVRS7233,
pretty diverse capsules,
you see exactly the same phenomena
where gene transfer is not inhibited.
Using this when challenged with the seed of these mice,
there is no inhibition of gene transfer at all
with MC46 and MC55.
So your holy grail capsid
has all three of these components augmented.
Last year, we showed you some data at ASGCT on Apex,
which is our generative AI modeling,
where we take a known capsid, a known natural isolate,
and we evolve the sequence space around it
with generative AI modeling
to find a retinotropic capsid
that is both manufacturable
and has high degree of retinotropism.
This year, we're talking about mad gas,
where instead of going this way,
we're going this way,
and discovering novel ABs by mining
this vast amount of available metagenomic space.
Why are we excited about this work?
We are excited about this work
because of the discovery potential, right?
So we have hit upon this,
what we think is this incredibly black box unexplored
mother lord of this rich vein of nav-naive capsids
that have exciting properties that we don't know about.
We are excited to find out more about the biology of this.
Why do these capsids,
how these capsids evolve to avoid nab recognition?
How is MC-46 doing what it's doing
in the non-human primate CNS,
and why it hasn't likely seen a primate?
Is it, does it have deep brain penetrance,
or is it limited to basically existing
or transducing the blood-brain barrier?
Does it actually cross it?
Are these novel capsids responsive to AVR,
or is there a different pathway by which they go through?
What is the natural receptor for these capsids?
So much, so much interesting biology that we are,
we are digging into and every day is an exciting day.
We're excited for the impact that it can have on patients.
Very clearly, this satisfies a very fundamental ask
from the capsid engineering community.
Can you give us a capsule that is completely nab naive?
And we are already working with some teams
on exploring this in the pre-clinical space.
If this is of interest to any of you,
please feel free to reach out,
and we'll have a chat on this.
We are completely open about sharing these.
We are completely, we really want people
to be using it if it's of interest.
And lastly, speaking as a capsid biologist,
I love this for the platform value that it brings.
Like it's, the value for us is now this is a chassis for us
to evolve capsid with desired properties based off on.
We've essentially switched from your AV9 and like
to these matcap capsids for our chassis almost immediately
because I think this is how we're gonna,
our lab or our team is gonna start doing capsid discovery.
So it takes a village, it's not just us.
I like to highlight three individuals,
Tess Tarragosa, Eugenia Lashanko and Alex Isasi,
who are the key contributors for this
and are the first authors in a manuscript
that is under review.
And I'd like to have a heartfelt thanks
for Christian Mueller, who's the global head of JMU,
for investing time and resource into something,
especially in the early days when it's blue sky research.
It's sometimes hard to do that with corporate KPIs
and term sheets and all of that.
So with that, thank you, and I'm happy to take questions.
Thank you.
Thank you, Sara.
Hi, nice talk.
I'm Dan Stone from Fred Hutch.
I'm also the associate editor in chief
of molecular therapy advances,
which I'll get to why I'm saying that in a second.
So many of us in the room have submitted AV sequences
and capsids to SRA.
So when you are panning this stuff,
if say I had a novel capsid that I'd submitted the SRA to
and I hadn't published it,
would that be captured in your novel AV
that you're pulling out?
So really, are you discovering things
that people have other discovered, already discovered,
or is this stuff that's coming from, say,
a non-AV related study that happens to have an AV in there?
The part one.
Okay.
The latter.
In fact, I can tell you that MC46 comes
from a completely unrelated study, nothing to do with AV,
generally more to do with a post-COVID virology screen
in a seafood market in Southeast Asia.
So nothing to do with AV.
Okay, great.
Thank you.
And then part two.
So at molecular therapy advances,
we publish a lot of novel AV capsids
and we see a lot of biotechs wanting to publish capsids,
but they call them AVXB, et cetera.
Since you are harvesting this from publicly available database,
are you willing to put these capsid sequences
back into the databases where you got them from?
Absolutely.
I speak for Sanofi here that we are incredibly open.
We've published Apex and other platforms we've published.
This is, as I said, in press.
We will absolutely have a full disclosure,
including not just the sequences, which is obvious,
but obviously also the code by which you discovered it,
in case there are things that we didn't discover,
that other people find interesting.
So we are entirely transparent.
That's fantastic, and I commend you
and I recommend that all other companies
that submit to any of the molecular therapy journals
have a similar...
I love it.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Hi, great talk.
Ashuna from University of Louisville.
So anything that we make novel
also can trigger the immunogenicity profile.
Have you looked into how this,
while the transduction is great,
but how does it trigger the innate
and the innate immunity of these?
Have you looked into the immunity profiles
of these animals that you have been investigating?
Great question.
We do.
We have not seen anything adverse.
The animals, the non-human primates,
seem to be able to tolerate it
with the specific set of trans genes with a caveat
that we have a specific set of trans genes
that we are interested in and so on and so forth.
With that caveat, we have seen no adverse effects.
We've seen some very interesting phenomena
in terms of, which we still have to confirm
in terms of it seems, whether it can be completely
re-dosed as a second dose by itself.
I think that study is ongoing,
but in terms of phenomena that might be interesting
to the clinical community, these behave
pretty much like other capsules.
Okay, thank you.
In the interest of time, maybe we can have the questions
later.
I see there are many more questions for you.
So maybe you can talk to all the people.
I would love to.
Please, please, please feel free to catch me.
Thank you, Saurabh.
Thank you.
Moving on to our next speaker.
And I want to emphasize here that he is a travel awardee.
And here we welcome John Zachary for his talk
on the structural investigation
of naturally occurring human anti-AV2 antibodies
with antigenic profile of AV2.
And welcome, John.
Hi, good morning, thank you.
All right, so as she said, my name's John,
and I am a PhD student at the University of Florida,
so I don't have any disclosures at this time.
I'm gonna go ahead and launch into a portion
of my dissertation work that we're working on currently.
So as we just heard, the use of AAVs in the clinic
uses a large variety of native occurring capsids,
and those capsids have preexisting,
neutralizing antibodies circulating
throughout the population.
In fact, as of last January,
about 80% of the clinical trials that had occurred
or were occurring at the time used native type capsids.
And as we've seen in the past few days,
the proportion of engineered capsids
can be expected to increase,
but the resistance through neutralizing antibodies
may not be affected by some of these changes.
And depending on the serotype that you investigate,
you can have anywhere from five to 95% seropositivity
for this neutralizing antibodies in your population.
In response to this, our lab recently,
and a few years ago, did a study using AV9 antibodies
that were sourced from Zoologism treated patients
that were neutralizing.
And then use high resolution cryoem data
in order to characterize where those exact antibodies
bound on the surface.
And from that, we determined about three quarters
of them bound to the surface
at the two full portion of the capsid.
And for those of you that aren't overly familiar
with the exact structure, I'll show that in a moment.
And then from this data,
we then developed a antibody escape capable variant
that was able to escape 17 of those 21 antibodies
that we investigated, maintained its tropism
and biodistributions and maintained transduction
in the presence of sera, both from these patients
that these antibodies were isolated from
and from patients whose antibodies weren't included
in this portion of the study.
Recently, there's been a, well, in 2022,
following the COVID lockdown,
there was an outbreak of pediatric hepatitis
and during the ideological studies for these,
patients were found to also be co-infected with AAV2.
This was not necessarily unexpected as many of the viruses
that were found to be part of this outbreak
were the common helper viruses for AAVs.
And using access to our collaborators,
we were able to generate samples of the antibodies
from these patients that are specific
to this native type infection for AAV2.
And so the goal of this work then is to clone out those
and generate a high resolution cryoAM data again,
in order to identify those specific epitopes
on the surface of the capsid and compare that for now
to the epitopes found in AAV9
and other mouse-derived anti-AAV2 antibodies.
And so beginning with the work from my collaborators,
they were able to isolate out these,
demonstrate both binding and neutralization in vitro,
which is important for this type of work.
And moving on from there, using high resolution cryoAM,
I've characterized the binding of 10 of these so far.
Go ahead and break that down for you.
The AAV capsid is an icosahedron,
and so it has a two-fold, three-fold,
and five-fold symmetry axes,
and these give rise to different important
structural features on the surface of the capsid.
And for the clusters of antibodies that I have,
five of these AAV2 antibodies bound around the three-fold,
which is about 50% of these,
two bound to the two-fold and three bound to the five-fold.
And then doing the same breakdown for AAV9,
just to remind us, as I said,
three-quarters of these 21 bound to the two-fold,
so that's about 16, if I remember correctly,
and then two bound to the three-fold
and three bound to the five-fold.
Now, this is a very interesting piece of information,
but structurally, why is this happening?
And so,
I must have pressed it back at some point, sorry.
All right, here we go, next slide.
All right, so just to re-orient you for a moment,
now we're looking down at a section of the capsid
that have been pulled out and look isolated,
and so the three-folds there,
represented by the triangles,
and the two-fold by this oval shape,
and I wanna draw your attention first
to these red squares on the top.
The top portions of the panel here
are hydrophobicity matrix six on the surface of the capsid,
and those two squares on the right are highlighting
two residues that are found within the two-fold pocket
on the surface of the capsid,
and these residues were bound by 100%
for the one on the furthest right,
and 50% of the antibodies that bounded the two-fold.
And then, looking onto the left box,
we see that there's this residue here,
this is a tryptophan that's found
in the center of the three-fold protrusions here,
and this was bound by both
of those three-fold binding antibodies.
Conversely, when we look at AAV2,
you can see that those hydrophobic spots
were represented by those orange colors are not present,
and AAV2, that right box has been changed
from a tyrosine to an asparagine,
no longer has this hydrophobic interaction surface,
and then the surface of the AAV2 capsid,
actually, at the three-fold protrusion,
extends out over the two-fold pocket
and presents itself and obscures the interaction
that would occur to the, oh, there's another one here.
That would obscures the interaction
to that other residue,
and the tryptophan also is not present in the AAV2 surface.
At the bottom panel now, we're looking
at an electrostatic representation of the capsid surface.
I'm gonna draw your attention to the pink squares.
Good.
And this pocket highlighted on the right for the AAV9,
it's an intensely negatively charged portion of the capsid,
which, in general, antibodies tend to favor,
though it's not entirely 100% of the time,
negative regions on antigenic surfaces,
and this pocket is obscured in AAV2
when we look at the left pink box.
I wanna draw your attention to the greater region
of the AAV2 surface, which highlights,
trying to highlight that there's just, in general,
a larger distribution of charges
across the AAV2 surface outside of that pocket,
so there's easier points to contact for AAV2
versus that deep pocket for AAV9.
And then when we make this a similar comparison
to mouse monoclonal antibodies
that were generated towards AAV2 in the past,
there are two so far that I wanna point out here.
We have Fab A20, which is a five-fold binder,
and Fab C37B, which is a three-fold binder,
and when we look at a stereographic representation
of the binding footprints of these antibodies,
we see that in the case of anti-AAV2 mouse antibodies,
they're fairly prototypic of what we see for humans,
and this is different from what we saw for AAV9,
where anti-AAV9 antibodies for mice
were not highly similar to human antibodies for AAV9.
This is true for all except for the two two-fold binders,
which for now there's not a mouse monoclonal antibody,
it's representative of these,
but in the past, work has been used A20
as a prototypic escape for human IVIG,
and so this kind of highlights some of the structural
underlying reasons for that capability.
Moving forward, we're taking this on
to develop an escape variant as we did in the past,
and I'm working on that currently.
So just as a summary,
talking about the antigenic profile of AAV2
seems to favor the three-fold a bit more than for AAV9,
and while this is one of our studies,
there are fairly few studies that fully characterize
the antigenic regions of AAVs in general,
and this represents right now the largest study
of human anti-AAV2 antibodies,
and is the only study that's conducted
on naturally occurring AAV2 infections
as opposed to a clinical application of a therapy,
and while I've highlighted some different structural reasons
for why these antibodies could interact differently
at the surface, there is also the difference
in the context of the infection for AAV9.
Presumably, there was no helper virus present
for these patients when they were treated,
and they were treated at a much higher dose
than they would have been if they were exposed
to AAV9 naturally, such as the case for these AAV2 patients,
and for the future, we're expanding this study
with another patient and other set of antibodies,
and then developing of an escape capable vector
for these pre-existing antibodies,
and I wanna thank my lab, my PI, Dr. Rob McKenna,
Mario, who will be giving a talk at 3.30 today
about AAV trafficking and seeing some really interesting
cool data coming out of our lab,
and our collaborators at the University of Sydney,
especially Dr. Grant, who will be giving a talk tomorrow
about more of this data concerning the AAV2 antibody
and immune response from these same patients
that were used for this study,
but in a different context tomorrow morning.
Thank you.
Thank you, John.
Questions?
There's one right there.
AAV2, a natural infection in presence of a helper virus
in AAV9 with Zolgensma,
I'm curious how these two,
because they're mapping to different regions,
but in most humans actually have
quite cross-reactive antibodies,
and I'm curious if you could talk about the differences
that you might have noticed in other studies
with cross-reactive antibodies in normal human's era,
and how well where those map to.
So in terms of cross-reactivity
for the antibodies we presented,
we did do, and let me see if I have it in here.
I don't have the cross-reactivity studies
for the AAV2 antibodies,
but we did those by native.immunable, sorry.
Should be right.
No, it's not on here, sorry.
Several of these were cross-reactive,
and we found that that kind of correlated,
cross-reactivity generally correlated
with some of the more conserved regions of the capsid.
The five-fold region especially,
which is highly conserved on the surface of the capsid,
tends to be more cross-reactive than others.
That was true for three of these for the AAV9,
possibly more, and that data is included
in those papers there.
And then for the AAV2, I have one's highly cross-reactive,
and that one also binds to the five-fold surface.
Great, thank you so much.
Great talk.
I may have missed this detail at the moment,
so this might be a really quick question for you.
Are these all neutralizing antibodies?
Yes.
Okay, do you have any reason to believe
why there might be a different landscape
in terms of whether binding for non-neutralizers
versus neutralizers, or do you think this would be
a common for both classes?
So, I've not looked at where non-neutralizing antibodies
would necessarily bind.
I don't know if we have that data, at least internally.
Haven't seen any in the literature,
but I would imagine that for non-neutralizing antibodies,
they would probably bind away
from where you would expect receptor sites,
and thereby are unable to inhibit transduction
directly on their own, but they're still fully capable
of recruiting other elements of the immune system,
complement, et cetera, in order to clear out the virus.
Hi, I'm Wunit from Seaver Research.
Thank you for presenting this.
It was very interesting, and I understood your assumption
that the differences you see might be associated
with the way of transduction, but have you considered
that difference in post-translational modifications
as part of the AAV manufacturing process
may contribute to these differences?
That is an interesting question, and I haven't looked into it,
but it's possible.
I don't really know, have the knowledge
to say much more right now.
So, there are some de-amidation sites
that have been shown to increase immunogenicity,
and are prone to occur in AAV in storage.
We can talk later.
Of course, thank you.
John, since we have a little bit of time,
I have a question.
So, do you have any specific amino acid residues
that are involved in on this contact point for the PAPS?
We have identified those, and for the sake
of my dissertation, I'm holding onto them
until I get it all worked out,
but I will be publishing that, and that will be available.
All right.
Is there any more questions for John, if not?
Thank you, John.
Thank you.
So, with that, I would like to invite our next speaker,
Simon Pecorre, and he will be talking
about a modular capsid engineering platform
to confirm neutralizing antibody evasion to CNS
and muscle-targeted AAVs.
Welcome.
Thank you.
Thanks for the opportunity to present our work today.
So, there are several ways we can deliver genes to the CNS.
You can go intraparenchymal.
You can deliver into the CSF, or go intravenous.
And because some brain diseases impact the entire brain,
we believe that there is a need to deliver cargos
and as many neurons of the CNS as possible.
And we believe that the only practical way of achieving that
is to use the vasculature, so the third one, and the GOIV.
But there are a couple of challenges
in achieving CNS, it's systemic gene delivery to the CNS.
One is that naturally occurring serotypes
do not cross the blood-brain barrier efficiently.
And the second one is that they're
susceptible to a neutralizing antibodies resulting
from pre-exposure to the virus.
So in the next few minutes, I'm going to tell you
how our lab tackled both challenges sequentially.
And we'll start with the BBB crossing.
So to cross the BBB, my colleagues Ken Shan, Helen Wong,
and Jean Lien reprogrammed AV-9 to bind to the human
transfer and receptor.
And this led to the discovery of a second generation human
transfer and receptor binding capsid
that we call BHGF01B2, aka TF01CAPX.
So if you want more information about this capsid,
I strongly recommend that you go to talk to my colleague Ken
Shan.
He's right here.
He'll be presenting this afternoon his poster number
3037 on BHGF01B2 characterization.
I'm just going to share a little piece of data here.
This second generation capsid is capable of efficient
transduction of the brain in human transfer and receptor
knocking animals, as seen on the right of that slide here.
It outperforms the first generation
variant BHGF01 as well as AV-9, and it mainly
transduces neurons.
And what's interesting to notice here
is we work in that type of study as a dose of 2E10VG
per kilogram, 2E12, sorry, which is about 50-fold lower
than Zolgenzma.
So lowering the dose is great because it
reduces the risk of toxicity.
But at the same time, if you lower the dose,
then you have more neutralizing antibodies per capsid.
And the neutralizing antibody problem becomes even bigger.
So that brings us to a second challenge.
So how did we take BHGF01B2 and further engineer it
to evade neutralizing antibodies?
So I want to start with a model of BHGF01B2 capsid.
It's an alpha-4-3 model.
And in blue is represented the region that
was engineered to bind to the human transfer and receptor.
So as you can see, it's a very small region of the capsid.
And the rest of the capsid actually looks like AV-9.
So to make it evade neutralizing antibodies,
we kind of decided that we had to disrupt
as many anti-AV-9 antibody epitopes as possible,
possibly with as few modifications as we could.
And we looked in nature and found
what strategy that was pretty appealing that
consists in modulating surface charge.
So we have seen that during COVID with the Omicron
variant that actually was shown to evade
the great majority of antibody-based drugs that
were developed to neutralize the original strain.
And this was attributed to a few mutations in the protein
spike that created a positively charged patch.
So the question became, can we apply this strategy to BHGF01B2
in order to make it evade neutralizing antibodies
while retaining its BBB crossing phenotype?
To do that, we started from the parental capsid, V2.
We identified surface-exposed target residues
that we mutated to either positively charge
neutral or negatively charge residue.
We took the resulting library, and we
screened it for production fitness,
for in vitro antibody evasion, as well as blood-brain
barrier crossing in human transfer and receptor
knocking animals.
We did that in two rounds, modified a total of seven
capsid regions, and characterized the selected
variants individually.
And to increase the probability of identifying
capsid scaffolds that would be compatible with other loop
eight modifications, we also added
three different peptides crossing the BBB in mice
using three different receptors, so EBBI28 and 9P31,
to the original library.
So first, we can walk through the NGS data.
Here's the production fitness profile of the library.
As you can see, AV9 and V2 have like pretty similar scores.
And we selected variants within that blue regions
that produced within a reasonable distance of AV9.
We looked at brain transduction in TF4C knocking animals,
and here each dot represents a variant with four
codon replicates, and you're looking at the
transduction score in one mice versus the other.
As expected, BHTF1V2 are performed AV9,
and we selected variants within that green region.
Last, we look at antibody evasion in H2993 cells.
And here I'm showing you the transduction score
in the absence of IVIG on the x-axis
versus presence of IVIG on the y-axis.
And we selected variants that had like a high score
in the presence of neutralizing antibodies.
So now when you take the intersection of these three
regions, you find a limited set of variants,
including one that we called BHTF1V2E for evasion,
and that we characterized more in detail.
So the first thing we did was to look at the surface
charge profile of V2E, and what we could observe
is that it was pretty different from the parental capsid
as expected, considering the strategy that was used
in that project.
So now, what is the impact of those modifications
on tropism?
We looked at that in human transfer
and receptor knocking animals.
You're looking at a comparative analysis of V2E,
V2 and AV9 in human transfer and knocking mice,
and you're looking at the transduction data on the left,
and VG by distribution data on the right.
And as you can see is that the BBB crossing phenotype
of V2E is maintained in V2E in spite of the differences
in surface charge.
Let's look at antibody evasion now in vitro.
So we did that with 73 human sera from individual donors,
and we used AV9, AV5, and BHTF1V2S controls.
So here I'm plotting all the neutralization curves
that were measured for sera neutralizing AV9,
color coded by their IC50, red meaning high neutralization
and blue meaning low neutralization.
So as you can see, the profile are pretty similar
for V9 and V2, but you see a lot of curves
that get like right shifted for V2E,
suggesting some level of antibody evasion.
And when you take that and measure the IC50
for all these human sera, they are all represented
as columns in that heat map.
You see that the IC50 values go down across the board
for V2E compared to the other three serotypes
with actually 40% of the human sera
that neutralize BHTF1V2 that exhibit IC50 below
or limit of detection of one of four for BHTF1V2E.
So that's good news.
It means like we're potentially able
to expand the patient pool for CNS gene therapy,
but we wanted to validate these results first in vivo.
So we worked on a model where we passively immunized
human transfer and receptor knocking animals
with IgG pre-fight from human sera.
A day later, we co-injected AV9, V2E and V2E IV.
And at day 21, we looked at function in the brain
by RTD PCR.
So let's look at the human sera first
from which we pre-fight IgG for the passive immunization.
You can see first that they have different
neutralization potencies with C being monetizing
then B and A overall.
And then you can also see that BHTF1V2E evades this sera
to a greater extent than the other two
because it's IC50 value.
It's actually lower when measured in vitro.
So now let's look at the sera of mice
that were passively immunized with these IgG.
So again, you can see that the mice that receive
the compound C or have a serum that's monetizing
to all three capsids compared to B and A.
And you also see those response at the 30 milligram dose
versus 10 milligram IgG per animal.
And again, BHTF1V2E show IC50 below
or limit of detection of one to 20 in that particular assay.
So now let's look at function.
This is the function in the absence of IgG.
So as you can see, V2 and V2E as expected outperform AV9.
And now when you look at all the conditions
and you normalize that score to the saline control,
you can see that you have a greater rescue
of your brain signal in animals treated with BHTF1V2E
as opposed to V2 and AV9 with a full change ranging
from three to 40 fold in serum C and B.
A wasn't neutralizing enough
that we could really observe anything in vivo.
So that enabled us to conclude that this serotype
was also capable of antibody evasion in vivo.
We looked at production titers
in suspension and adherence cells.
And in the absence of optimization,
we were able to produce V2E within a two-fold of AV9.
And we were able to also show
that it was compatible with porous AVX, AV pure AV9
for a capture affinity chromatography, but not porous AV9.
Last, we wanted to see whether
some of our antibody evading scaffolds
were compatible with muscle targeting peptides.
So we identified five potential candidates
that we combined with two muscle peptide myoav4A
as well as one that we call RGD1.
And we characterized the resulting variants.
And so we were able to show that one was compatible
with both and we followed up on this one
with the RGD1 peptide only.
And if you look at antibody neutralization in vitro,
the second generation that we call RGD1 Gen2
was able to evade preexisting antibodies
in about 32% of the human Sierra that neutralized RGD1.
And this year, we further evolved it
and we went up to around 56%.
And last, we looked at function in C57 animals
and we saw no major difference in muscle between RGD1,
RGD1 Gen2 and Gen3.
So to finish, this is actually a gift
of the surface charge modulation between RGD,
RGD1 Gen2 and Gen3.
And this brings us to a conclusion
and we applied a charge alteration with a genesis
to CNS and muscle tropic capsids.
The resulting variants maintained their enhanced tropism.
They were able to produce within two-fold of AV9
and they evaded 40 to 56% of the human Sierra
that neutralized AV9.
So this method is potentially applicable
to any tissue-specific capsids.
And with this, I would like to thank all my lab mates
and colleagues and collaborators from the Deverman Lab
and the Varadmini Care Lab at the Broad,
especially Ken Shan, Jean Lien, and Jenselyn Johnston,
who took care of all the NBSA,
as well as Pam Brower and John Harvey
for the manufacturing.
And I'll be happy to take any questions.
Thank you.
Thank you, Simon.
And we have questions over here.
Excellent talk.
So I think you said you looked in seven different areas.
How many edits did the best capsid end up having?
How many mutations?
Yes.
More than you can count on, let's say,
between 10 and 50.
Okay, great, thank you.
Thanks for your talk.
I have a conceptual question on the results
of your library that looks like you had the same approach
of modifying the charge surface for all your library on you,
showcase some kind of positive candidate.
Did you try to extract the negative one
on to redox the neutralizing antibodies
to try to identify which position was actually involving
that kind of conceptual evading of that?
When do you plan to finally make this data accessible?
You're talking about the dual production fitness
distribution?
No, it's in the way you modify your variant,
you consider on your top right of your graphics,
the selection of your top variant that is evading,
but you may have several AVs vector
that have a modification of the charge surface,
but without evading the system.
So you can envision to redox actually
the neutralizing antibody itself to see
what is the difference, functional difference
between what works to what doesn't work finally
at the level of your pure capsid to antibodies binding.
Yeah, we initiated some work in that direction,
but I think it's not as mature as you would expect.
Thank you.
So I don't see any more questions.
Oh, there is one.
Beautiful talk, Simo.
Thanks.
I love that you tested both AVX and the AV9 porous resin,
and you saw a major difference there,
but what about things like anion exchange columns
and other downstream purificate?
How do you think that this charge modifications
will affect things like that?
Yeah, TBG, we haven't looked into that either yet.
Very great work.
Thank you.
Thank you, Simo.
So with that, we have our last presentation
from Adrian Sevi, and he will be talking
about one AAV capsid from Coyev,
and he is from Coyev Therapeutics, and it's all yours.
Thank you for the introduction,
and first of all, thanks to the organizer
for giving me the opportunity to present
how we are redefining targeting gene therapy
at Coyev Therapeutics.
And today, we'll talk about capsid engineering.
We are doing bioconjugation.
Why?
It's mainly to address the key challenges
of IV injection.
The first one is the targeting.
How do we bring the vector to the tissue of interest?
Bioconjugation allows more efficient conjugated capsid
because we are looking for non-mechanisms.
How do we do it?
We first rationally design ligands
that interact with human receptor with the non-mechanisms.
And we have a very modular platform
that is based on chemical conjugation,
creating a covalent bond.
It's irreversible and does not require any catalyst.
This is very modular.
We can really fine-tune the coupling level
to perfectly match the requirements
of the targeted receptors.
And as we are completely decoupling the tropisms
from the capsid, we can integrate this platform
to any existing AVs, wild type, engineers, and so on.
At Coyev, we have many different kinds of ligands
from small molecules to peptides to VHH.
Each of them is rationally designed
to target a specific receptor and also to allow
a cross-reactivity among species
and mostly between human and NHPs.
To simplify it, you can see it like antibody drug conjugate
but applied to AVs.
So once we perform our bioconjugation,
we are creating a new generation of targeted vectors.
And at Coyev, we have three main focuses
in ophthalmology, in CNS, and for muscle diseases.
I don't know if you had the chance to attempt earlier
this morning to our new supra-coryidal capsids
but if you want, do not hesitate to be in touch.
And I also strongly recommend you to attempt later today
to the Poster 3026 from my colleague Lavagna
that will present how the ligand conjugation
is enabling cross-paces crossing
through human TFR1 receptor.
If we talk about the CNS and we have a look
to our AV9 BBB crossings through TFR1 workflow,
we first design the ligands and we can do that
because we are doing bioconjugation.
We are not interested by the capsid.
It's really the ligands that we are working on it.
We are really designed them to be specific
for a human receptor but also to work in NHPs.
And thanks to the bioconjugation and to our chemistry,
we can really fine tune the coupling level.
We can clearly increase how many ligands we put
at the capsid surface and it's
tightly managed control process.
We then screened our conjugated AVs in vitro.
In the example with two cell lines,
the first one, a human expressing the transfer
in one receptor cell line.
And our two conjugated AV9 either with a ligand one
or two have the same transaction efficiency
as the published TFR1 benchmark.
But if we switch to a Sino-expressing TFR1 cell line,
our two conjugated AV9 either in blue or green,
maintains their transaction efficiency
whereas the published TFR1 benchmark does not.
We then move to in vivo screening.
And you know the AV9 is a poor brain transducer
when injected by IV.
But if you take the exact same AV9
and you conjugate it with our TFR1 ligands,
it's knocking humanized mice,
you can see that the transaction efficiency
is greatly improved with the world brain transduction.
If we look at the RNA expression,
we have a 40-fold difference in term of expression
compared to AV9 in purple.
And we are perfectly matching the published benchmark
in term of brain transduction.
But we also have a second effect.
We have a very strong liver detargeting
with our conjugated AV9 with more than 15 fold decrease
in liver expression.
Our platform is something that is very versatile,
so we can move from the brain to the muscles.
And if we take the exact same AV9 capsid backbone
and with this time conjugated with a peptide
that has been designed to interact
with the integrin alpha V beta 6,
we obtain a conjugated AV9 targeting these integrins.
And this time we have a 300 fold increase
in the gastrocnemius muscles
and the 200 fold increase in the quadriceps,
both reaching the published beta 6 benchmark again.
So the Alligator platform is something
that is very versatile, it's very tunable,
and it's highly scalable.
We can do that because again,
we are doing bio-conjugations.
We are not that interested by the capsid,
only by the ligands.
And we wanted to go beyond in term of addressing
the IV challenges.
So the first one was the targeting,
I think that we can fix it easily now,
but we wanted to go really beyond
and address two other challenges.
The first one was the immunovasion.
And to do that, we created one AV capsid family,
it's kind of proof of concept.
It has been designed to completely
decorelate the tropisms from the capsid.
We wanted a kind of complete neutral shell,
and it has been engineered
from low seroprevalence serotypes in humans
to address the immune response problems.
And we also engineered them
to completely obtain a lever day targeting.
So we had a neutral shell
without any interaction on its own.
And thanks to the Alligator platform,
we can strongly retarget them to tissue of interest.
We first validated our one AV capsid by IV injections.
Quite a high dose for 10 to the 13 VG per KIG
with the luciferous transgene under the KAK promoter.
And we compare it to the AV9
in both male and female wild type mice.
As expected for the AV9 groups,
we saw very strong expression in the lever,
whereas the expression was barely detectable
with our one AV.
We wanted to know where went the vectors.
So three weeks but in election at Sacrifice,
we look at the vector copy number in different tissue.
And in the lever, we have 800 for lower copy number
compared to the AV9
with an astonishing 0.03 vector copy per cell.
This I believe is a truly worthy targeting.
Our non-conjugated one AV does not cross the BBB on its own.
We have a thousand for lower expression,
not expression, vector copy number in the brain.
And it was quite the same in every peripheral organs
that we have looked at.
So we know we have this neutral shell.
What can we do with it?
And what is happening if we conjugated it
with the TFR1 ligands?
We first confirm an unprecedented lever de-targeting
with a thousand for lower expression.
In the lever, you can see the AV9 expression,
the lever in purple,
and our conjugated TFR1 when AV capsid
is here with a thousand fold.
In the heart, we have 400 fold.
But this conjugated one AV is perfectly able
to cross the BBB and to express in the brain.
When we compare to the AV9 on the left
and the TFR1 conjugated one AV on the right,
I think it's quite clear that this vector is able
to cross the BBB and to express in the deep brain regions.
And if we zoom in, we know that the AV9
does not have any neuronal tropisms,
whereas our conjugated one AV
has a very strong neuronal tropism.
We continue with beta-6 integrins targeting peptides.
In wild type mice this time,
we confirm again a very strong lever de-targeting
with a 500 fold compared to AV9.
The non-conjugated one AV is in red
and the conjugated is in blue.
In both muscles, quadriceps and gastrocnemius,
we have not been able to detect any expression
of the non-conjugated vectors.
But once it's conjugated with the beta-6
targeting TFR1,
this time we are between five and 10 fold higher
in term of expression compared to AV9.
Because we are doing bio-conjugation
and we are working on the ligands,
we have been able to create this first generation
of one AV capsid.
It's the very first capsid with no tropisms on its own.
It's quite inert.
It has an unprecedented lever de-targeting.
It's highly manufacturable.
It's very similar to AV9 in term of yield.
It's based on low seroprevalent serotypes,
but thanks to the alligator platform and the chemistry,
we can really target the vector on demand
only in the tissue of interest.
In conclusion, the alligator platform allows us
to have cross reactive ligands among species
with a very strong lever and very strong tissue targeting.
We went from AV9 to benchmark expression level
in both the CNS and in mussels.
And we believe that the combination
of the bio-conjugation, the alligator platform,
and the one AV, we will pave the way
of a certain generation of vectors
that is safer and more potent.
Thank you very much.
And I would like to thank all co-members
for this amazing work and mainly the bio-conjugation team
which is here because without the girls,
nothing would have been possible.
Thank you.
Very interesting work.
I am a bit concerned about the generalization
claim of this platform,
given that the transference receptor as far as I know
is judging by symbol linear peptide.
So how do we feel the generalization
to more complex receptor requirements
like things that requires conformational rigidity
or things that require limberization,
depending on judgment or things that require
ligand clustering?
How you feel about this?
I'm not completely sure, to be honest,
to have fully understood your question.
Very simply, how do you think this would generalize
to other receptors that have more complex requirements
to get in judging?
That can be either more complex ligand,
some has conformational requirements
or clustering of more ligands,
or...
I get it.
...limberization, things.
Yeah, again, we are decorating the capsid.
We are first screening the ligands
to match the receptors.
We know that our ligands are reactive
with a receptor of interest,
and then we conjugate them to the capsid.
Hi, Dmitri from Ring Therapeutics.
Very nice talk and very cool platform.
I'm curious, with the TFR data you showed,
since you mentioned that there's not
kind of an intrinsic tropism of the capsid,
how much more is the TFR doing after the BBB crossing
to give you the actual transduction of the neurons?
How are you actually targeting neurons?
Is there additional liganding,
or is it just an increased concentration in the brain
that is leading to that transduction?
It's a very good question.
I can't answer it.
It's a very preliminary work,
but we are looking into it.
Thank you.
Hello, great talk.
Hugh from there, Therapeutics.
I'm sorry if I missed this in the talk,
but what was the method of finding
the kind of neutral-based capsid?
Is it one that exists,
or did you have to do a lot of editing to make it neutral?
We first generated a rational library.
It was a very tiny one.
It was only 10 capsids.
So, yeah, very rational.
All right, okay, great.
Thanks very much.
And no question from Anna.
Thank you.
A capsid with zero tropism is fascinating in and of itself,
but where is that blockade?
Is it just not entering any cells?
Is it not trafficking?
Is it just coming out in the urine
because it's not, where's the block?
I was thinking that you can help me on that.
When we look on the vector distribution,
the copy numbers,
we have not been able to find it anywhere, to be honest.
We also perform a kinetic study in the sera
to try to find if we were just circulating longer,
but no, it's the same as AV9.
And yeah, we are thinking about the urines,
but we did not collect them.
Yeah, very, great work.
Thank you.
Thank you, Anna.
Sorry, sort of related to that.
Have you looked at interactions of the base capsid
with things like AVR?
It's ongoing.
Adrian, so have you looked into the shelf life,
physical stability, aggregation profile of this new capsid?
It's ongoing work,
but the designs that we have performed on this capsid
should not change the parental one property.
So without disclosing the serotype,
we are confident that everything will go well.
Can you talk a little bit about the site specificity
of your conjugation method?
Sorry, can you repeat?
Can you talk a little bit about
whether your conjugation method is site specific?
We are conjugating a natural amino acid
that's a capsid surface.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Any more questions?
If not, then I'll conclude the session here.
And if you have time,
please provide the feedback for the session.
It is really helpful for the ASGCT for organization.
And thank you all for coming.